pintando girasoles sobre un montón de
carros quemados y destruidos en los
primeros días de la guerra en ucrania
artistas ucranianos intentan transformar
un ambiente hostil en uno de esperanza
queremos conservar el recuerdo de los
que murieron para demostrar que la vida
continúa que ganaremos y que podemos
vencer al enemigo ya sea con un pincel o
con las armas queremos mostrar al mundo
que somos una nación fuerte someterán a
ser estos valientes artistas cuentan con
el apoyo de una empresa estadounidense y
algunos distribuidores locales reciben
donaciones de pintura y otros
suministros necesarios para llenar las
calles de color en las ciudades hay
paredes y áreas específicas para que
reflejen de manera optimista la triste
realidad en la que viven
este es un proyecto interesante debe
presentar nuestro problema en el
escenario mundial la comunidad
internacional y los ciudadanos de los
países que nos apoyen son nuestro
público no deberían dejar de prestarnos
ayuda
sin embargo el proyecto ha suscitado
algunas críticas por parte de quienes
dicen que no es correcto crear belleza a
partir de los restos de la guerra
yo entiendo la idea de que las flores
muestren esperanza en el futuro y que
ucrania no puede ser destruida a pesar
de que los rusos lo intenten pero no sé
tal vez sea demasiado pronto tal vez sea
demasiado pronto para dibujar flores no
estoy seguro pero entiendo la idea
pero los artistas insisten en que su
trabajo mejorará el ánimo de todos los
afectados por la guerra y que ayudará a
los artistas ucranianos ya los esfuerzos
generales de reconstrucción pues el
colectivo venderá sus obras en formato
digital para recaudar fondos para causas
locales